music like i was just my friend just
yesterday was like hey what's going on i
live in arizona i live in scottsdale and
she was like asking for fun things to do
and so i said you know
hiking is really good right now and then
i said but it
sucks that there's no concerts
like it really sucks it's a huge loss
that there aren't
concerts well i was reading something
recently that you know the last
global pandemic was in 1918
right spanish right yeah and
a lot of i guess historians or
anthropologists think that the roaring
20s
was actually a response to that pandemic
you know that like basically in 1917
1918 1919 1920 apparently like
the world was even more shut down than
it is now really
okay just think of it like they didn't
have phones they didn't have
you know like everything i mean all jobs
were in-person
jobs back then so like when that
pandemic
waned apparently people just went crazy
and that's where the roaring 20s came
from so i heard someone saying like
get ready because it's about to happen
again you know like once this pandemic
abates or ends i feel like
people are just gonna rush to concert
venues to nightclubs to bars to
restaurants
to anything you know like i mean
i'm old and kind of misanthropic and i
like being by myself so
i don't know if i'll be rushing
totally you're gonna be playing you're
gonna be doing it you're gonna be
entertaining
us you're gonna comprise number two
yeah one of my only issues i don't
really like i love playing live music
but i really don't like touring mm-hmm
because i guess i just i did it for too
many years
and it just got too repetitive so now
like
most of the performing i do well
pre-pandemic was
you know at charity fundraisers friends
parties like i'd much rather
walk down the street with an acoustic
guitar and play some songs
in someone's backyard then go on tour
for six months
i have a nice walking guard walking
walking from la to scottsdale
that would be a little of a bit of a
chat like crossing the desert with my
acoustic guitar i feel like that would
be a good
there's a good movie in that we can meet
at coachella for a little tiny concert
yeah um scottsdale is that in arizona is
that
more towards the north or the south it's
it's really right where phoenix is
okay yeah is there
because i still remember this has
nothing to do with almost anything we're
talking about but the first
tour i ever did we had two days off
after a show in phoenix and so a bunch
of friends and i
rented a car and drove to the grand
canyon because we'd never been to the
grand canyon
and i remember one of the most
remarkable experiences we left
phoenix and it was this was it was in
february we left phoenix and it was like
68 degrees
and an hour later i think we went we
drove over
this thing called mount mariah
is that a real thing or am i missed well
you probably drove up to flagstaff
we eventually got to flagstaff but i
just remember like leaving phoenix going
up a mountain
and all of a sudden there's 10 feet of
snow everywhere yeah yeah so
what happens in arizona is everybody a
lot of times people get
a house there for the summer in the
summer have an extra house because it's
120 degrees in scottsdale or phoenix and
then they go to
flagstaff area where it's like eight
thousand foot
eight to twelve thousand i mean it goes
up to twelve thousand feet where uh the
top of the mountain is
um but eight about eight thousand feet
and it's 20 plus degrees cooler
yeah so yeah the west coast
because i grew up in connecticut and new
york and
what you're describing that just doesn't
exist anywhere on the east coast or the
midwest and like
when i first came out here i live in l.a
now
yeah and i realized like oh i live in la
it's 72 degrees but if i drive for two
hours i can be in 10 feet of snow
and it's 20 degrees you know that
is just it's still mind-boggling to me i
mean look
it seems like everyone's leaving
california maybe you want to come
to arizona the 120 degree summers
might might be a little hard to
to deal with well i understand that's
okay
um turns out there's plenty of space
everywhere for everyone
um i uh so you have a doc coming out too
i feel like you've been super
busy and um i just love the name of it
movie doc that's fantastic
why'd you decide to do it why did you
decide to do a doc
well it's interesting i i hope it's
interesting
and it ties back to what we've been
talking about because as you know there
are a lot
of biopics you know documentaries about
writers artists directors musicians
public figures
and one of the things i think i've
learned over time
is you know that and we
and i apologize for repeating myself but
that
the human condition can't be fixed with
fame
it can't be fixed with money it can't be
fixed
with possessions
and so the documentary is largely
i think the goal was to make something
unique and idiosyncratic
that looks at that issue you know like
using me as the
test subject almost like how i tried to
fix
you know so many you know psychological
things
with fame or money or
you know validation or materialism
and not surprisingly it didn't work
so that's the idea behind the
documentary to show that
you know you just can't you can't
fix yourself with fame and stuff
um well you said the more successful you
got essentially the
more alone you felt right or the the
worse you felt which i think
i mean it's it's funny because we're
still surprised when people have that
experience
but almost everybody has that experience
i mean like just recently there was the
meghan markle interview with oprah
you know she's a princess
hanging out in buckingham palace and
she's despondent and wants to kill
herself you know like and we're all so
surprised by that but like
but yeah that happened to diana too and
and it happened to kurt cobain and it
happened to ernest hemingway and it
happened to avicii and it happened
to robin williams and on and on and on
like
like really and i'm not complaining or
looking for sympathy
but as you probably know firsthand like
fame should come with a warning label
like
just beware like you think fame is going
to fix things
but boy oh boy it just doesn't um i love
like i think
maybe it's jim carr i'm sure plenty of
people kind of said this very
sort of thing but jim carrey like i wish
everyone could get rich and famous so
they could realize that it's not
like that's not the be-all end-all like
that's not going to fix anything
i mean they're nice obviously and i
apologize again for staying
obvious but there are nice aspects it's
nice to be able to pay the rent
it's nice to be able to see the world
it's nice to have recognition for what
you
love to do but boy oh boy whenever
anyone expects
fame and attention to fix
their innermost issues
uh i mean just history is just littered
with people for whom
you know the process of getting fame has
cut their life expectancy by about 80
you know sometimes there are like
reports on work safety
yeah and they'll say like well the most
dangerous job in the world is being an
alaskan fisherman
and in terms of life expectancy the most
dangerous job in the world is being a
public figure
it is true public figures have their
shortest life expectancy
you know think like amy winehouse if
she'd never become famous
she probably would live to be 70. kurt
cobain without saying he'd probably
still be alive
jimi hendrix jim morrison janice joplin
john lennon on and i mean avicii poor
avicii died in his
killed himself in his 20s you know like
so
so what's the catch like what's the what
is what's what's the safety net or
what's the what's the rope that's going
to pull you back in because
you know we're looking at it on a really
magnified scale or a public scale of
being famous and it kind of exacerbates
things
but i think that there's a there's a
correlation between
that and everything else so there must
be
the rope that you can hang on to to pull
you out of the [ __ ] and
what is that that's a great question
i i have to think that maybe it's maybe
it's different
for different people you know like some
people like i'm grateful for the fact
that i bottomed out completely you know
like before i got sober
12 years ago like i was suicidal
depressed
anxious despondent
and i'm grateful for it because it
forced me to do the work
to try and get better you know if i had
never bottomed out that way
i never would have been compelled to do
the work
but for other people they don't need to
bottom out you know other people it's
just simply having a great
you know being being smart having a
great education
um not having an addictive personality
uh having a good family structure good
friend structure
you know like not everybody needs to get
to the place that i got to of like this
you know suicidal dark night of the soul
so i guess different people are saved by
different things and very sadly
some people simply aren't saved